hi guys in the 21st century will face
this challenge of survival as a species
now the World Economic Forum is having
their meaning and they're asking folks
how do we increase global growth few
sustainability how can we increase
global growth through a greater
sustainability educate people what that
global brand names how can we increase
energy efficiency yes how can we
increase energy efficiency where you
have to have insulation in the hole DEP
DEP double-pane windows you have to buy
appliances that are as they say nowadays
star rating how can people on this
planet increase energy efficiency solar
power is really good decide will always
be there you know it's kind of harder
Washington since they never hardly ever
see the Sun your ottoman rest on this
planet introducing stuff that we use
less energy and get more of the product
that's something that we do on the other
planet that's something that's not in
here well Tony what is your company
doing to lower the carbon emissions on
this world we're spending at a hatter at
a rate that we can't really stabilize I
mean we have a limited amount of
resources on the planet Earth and we
have we think that we have an unlimited
growth source and at some point those
two numbers reach a point where they
can't continue on you more cheer don't
look just ten years into the future look
at fifty to a hundred years into the
future we need to look into our future a
lot further not just for us but our
children and our grandchildren how are
the future generations going to think of
you today's business leaders i'm melissa
rodriguez from recife brazil thank you
very much